hello ed Helmes here hi it's Owen Wilson
and we are doing the wired interview
autocompletes interview you better
believe it
so so should I pull it all right all
right is Owen Wilson
a professional skateboarder I think so
yeah
I enjoy it I've seen some Tony Hawk
urban Stabler do it that's a yes and
though I have been out yet to think
about it is Owen Wilson vegan yeah I try
to eat healthy so what vegan means no
cheese also yeah not no animal products
at all no honey no cheese no Barry you
can have bacon it okay so I'm pretty
much yeah is Wilson related to Matthew
McConaughey we are both from Texas and
there's a brotherhood
mmm that exists in people that went to
the University of Texas fraternal order
of Tejas yeah is Owen Wilson related to
Ellen DeGeneres where are you going with
this Google yeah I've been on the show a
number of times and there's a chemistry
there I could see how wow it's almost as
if they're related but in fact we're not
why is almost an uncredited night at the
Museum
that's Ed Helms that's actually I am
credited I play the little cowboy
Jedediah and you're uncredited in the
second one am I
I think I'm credited okay well then
maybe I'm not credited then it's my
question to why am i what is Owen Wilson
doing now well I'm playing I'm playing
this game I think I'm doing pretty well
I think you're nailing it except for
that vegan question yeah
why does ed Helms always sing you and me
both Google well there's a very good
reason for it and it's that I
from singing voice does edy he'll have a
brother okay I have an older brother he
lives in Washington DC and has a
beautiful family and I love him very
much did Ed Helmes really lose teeth
didn't we all yeah but yes I get this
question all the time the missing tooth
from The Hangover I never had an adult
tooth come in I've always had a gap
there so I've always had a fake tooth
and for the movie they took it out oh
that's good and and then put it back in
how did Ed Helmes get fat
he's not even fatties or get famous how
did Ed nomes get famous this whole day
you've just been wandering in the back
okay like I could never say that if you
really were ironically I am famous for
for winning a hot dog eating gonna mi
being overly sensitive like not happy
boring how did that a famous no no I
think they're saying was it from the
hangover was it from The Daily Show
Daily Show is the first thing that that
sort of put me on the map in terms of
show business so but it was kind of a
gradual thing napped in the office and
then night at the music - uncredited
does Owen Wilson say WOW in cars I do
say it does Owen Wilson say Wow in
behind enemy lines is that really a
question I probably do I bet I probably
do but I don't know for sure about that
one does Owen Wilson say WOW in Barley's
sure Marly in man yeah oh that's a very
different movie Marly in me morally in
yeah I probably do say it in that one
give us go oughta give us a little Wow
how great they are does Owen Wilson say
WOW in wedding crashers in wedding cards
I don't
absolutely you do okay does Owen Wilson
say wow a Night at the Museum it's a
little bit of
friend here ya know I bet I don't miss
Jedediah and no escape I don't do it
there but there's a new catchphrase that
I began in no escape and I've continued
into father figure so if you can
identify this new word this new word is
gonna make the old world look like just
nothing can I guess yeah is it is EDL
nice yes
his Edie Helms related to James a meal
is oh not to my knowledge and I don't
know who that is
Edie Helms related to Jason Sudeikis
also not to my knowledge
though he is an extremely funny man is
Edie Helms a vegetarian how the vegan
vegetarian community is really looking
for how I shoud hours no I'm not I'm not
a vegetarian
what is Ed Helms doing later tonight hmm
what am i doing now just I'm on this
press junket right now oh nice
and I'm just trying to make the world a
better place yeah what's oh in Wilson's
first movie bottle rocket okay what high
school did Owen Wilson go to like New
Mexico Military Institute but that's
after st. George yeah st. marqs st.
Marya and Thomas Jefferson
what does Owen Wilson look like how
about a golden retriever can we say that
you owe me favors
what does Owen Wilson build in Meet the
Parents oh I know this one why this is
on my favorite line out of that movie
yeah I'll answer this you know and the
parents built eight but a hapa there we
go thank you everybody and thank you for
playing wired autofill righto
[Music]